big name golfers back at the shriners
open which we've now learned will be
staying in las vegas for the foreseeable
future so good news there oh victoria
zaha joining us live this morning on the
green and she's already better than i am
victoria good morning
well i wouldn't say that just yet
heather i still got a lot of work to do
but here at tpc in summerland we're
already seeing a huge crowd
the ceremonial t just took off it had
seth here who's joining me now he was
part of the ceremonial team with two
other ambassadors he's one of the
children's ambassadors for the hospital
so all eyes were on you what was going
through your head i was just making sure
that i got all the timing right i was
tasked with making sure that you know
three two one go and then once i took it
back i said oh shoot i still have to hit
the ball but it was really fun
it looked intense um you have a personal
connection to the hospital can you tell
us a little bit about your story yeah so
in between fifth and sixth grade i was
diagnosed with scoliosis and i
immediately began work with a
chiropractor but we quickly realized it
wasn't going to be enough i needed
something else to help treat me so
luckily we found shriners had this new
surgery called vbt vertebral body
tethering that wasn't fda approved at
the time so i was part of the trial
testing and now it is fda approved so it
was definitely a big success
and you are a pro golfer almost right do
you have some favorite players here
today yeah actually on tuesday we met
zach johnson and he's just an awesome
guy really cool he gave us a new putter
new pair of oakleys awesome guy can
couldn't talk highly enough of them
thanks so much seth so 144 players are
here around the world teeing off and 70
thousand fans are expected to be here
throughout the weekend this event goes
until sunday october 10th it's going to
be 30 dollars to get in
heather and john back to you thank you
very much victoria good to meet the
ambassadors for shriners hospital so he
gets to make the cut to the weekend of
the tournament